the Kurdish people are one of the
world's largest ethnic groups without a
country of their own this has made them
vulnerable to persecution mass
displacement and ethnic cleansing though
they practice a handful of religions the
majority are Sunni Muslims their ethnic
origins are thought to be indo-european
and Persian not Arab after World War one
the Allied powers carved up the former
Ottoman Empire and promised the Kurds a
state that never happened the Kurds are
displaced throughout what is called
unofficial Kurdistan an area that
roughly includes parts of Turkey Iran
Syria and Iraq most live in Turkey and
in Iraq they have a semi-autonomous
government now with instability raging
across Syria and Iraq the possibility of
a Kurdish state at least in Iraq is
closer than ever
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook